[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología y debido a la
situación que vivimos a causa del coi 19
continuamos llevándoles toda la
información desde nuestros hogares
soy valentina torre sánchez gracias por
acompañarme con la atención puesta en
las vacunas contra el coronavirus poco
se habla acerca de los tratamientos que
actualmente existen para luchar contra
la enfermedad aunque no hay una droga
milagrosa ha habido avances en algunas
terapias que pueden ayudar a las
personas a que la enfermedad sea más
leve oa recuperarse más rápido veamos el
siguiente informe
si bien ha habido gran éxito con las
vacunas contra el coronavirus o la
búsqueda de tratamientos efectivos
continúan hasta ahora los
corticosteroides son la única clase de
fármacos que ha demostrado eficacia para
reducir la mortalidad por kobe 19
reducen la inflamación y la actividad
del sistema inmunológico sin embargo hay
algunos tratamientos prometedores en
desarrollo por ejemplo anticuerpos
monoclonales el mismo tratamiento que
recibió el expresidente donald trump
cuando luchó contra el cob y así
funciona inyectado por vía intravenosa
el tratamiento imita la reacción del
sistema inmunológico a la infección
bloqueando las proteínas del virus que
le permiten adherirse a las células y
entrar en ellas es caro y debe ser
administrado en un hospital pero los
estudios muestran que reduce las tasas
de mortalidad y ante receta xxi son
cometidos con el resultado son
prometedores si se da un diagnóstico muy
muy temprano es muy útil notablemente en
personas con factores de riesgo desde
festejos del disc pero hay
preocupaciones sobre su eficacia ante
las mutaciones como la surgida en
sudáfrica
y se están publicando varios artículos
en las revistas por empresas que
muestran que en lo que respecta a los
anticuerpos monoclonales la mutación
niega completamente la eficacia de
varios de ellos y el indigente que se
pone de 1.006 jon otro tratamiento
observar colchicina un antiinflamatorio
utilizado para prevenir los ataques de
gota un estudio canadiense mostró éxito
para combatir el hobbit y reducir el
riesgo de complicaciones en cuanto a las
grandes esperanzas anteriores hidroxi
cloroquina y recibir los estudios no han
demostrado de manera concluyente que
sean efectivos en pacientes enfermos
vamos ahora a eeuu puntualmente al
aeropuerto internacional de oakland en
california donde hay dos máquinas
expendedoras que en lugar de entregar
comida o dispositivos electrónicos
venden pruebas de ccoo y 19 se trata de
una iniciativa de la empresa wellness
for humanity y los test que cuestan 149
dólares son de saliva por lo que el
resultado está listo en entre 24 y 48
horas el público objetivo de la compañía
son los viajeros que llegan a la ciudad
pues deben enviar su muestra por la
empresa de mensajería fedex y luego
reciben su resultado
holtz y en esta máquina expendedora está
nuestro tcpr casero de saliva pueden
comprarlo aquí viene con una etiqueta de
regreso y un kit de recolección de la
muestra
[Música]
es la primera prueba casera de saliva
autorizada por la administración de
medicamentos y alimentos y luego tomas
la muestra recolectada y con la etiqueta
la envías al laboratorio y cuando el
laboratorio de la recibe te entrega los
resultados en entre 24 y 48 horas está
aprobada para viajeros y tiene una
precisión del 99 por ciento y no incluso
los responsables indican que trabajan
para que pronto haya pruebas express
disponibles para las personas que salen
de viaje y que requieren los resultados
de inmediato ellos podrán acceder a sus
resultados en 15 minutos o pueden en las
esperamos que en las próximas semanas
tengamos un kit rápido de antígeno que
es preciso en un 97,4 por ciento y de
resultados inmediatos
estamos abiertos a expandirnos inc
ahora mismo nuestra meta es que con
nuestros socios desplegamos mil de estas
máquinas alrededor del país
especialmente en zonas del tránsito como
metros aeropuertos tiendas y queremos
enfocarnos en el mercado interno pero
estamos abiertos expandirnos
internacional
y finalizamos con un hecho histórico
porque emiratos árabes unidos- se
convirtió en el primer país árabe en
poner una sonda en la órbita de marte se
trata de joe que llegó hasta la órbita
del planeta rojo tras un viaje de siete
meses y unos 500 millones de kilómetros
esto permitirá que nuestros
investigadores y nuestros futuros
científicos llegar a un punto en el que
podrán trabajar con la comunidad global
de ciencia marciana en un corto periodo
pues iniciamos esta misión hace siete
años es un corto lapso para que
cualquier nación entre en una comunidad
científica y este es uno de los
principales propulsores de nuestra
exploración espacial spacex presión
durante los próximos dos meses
realizará pruebas para comprobar el
correcto funcionamiento de sus
instrumentos y sistemas y luego se prevé
que durante cuatro años órbita alrededor
de marte para recolectar información
sobre la atmósfera del planeta su clima
y sus estaciones
así finalizamos este espacio a ustedes
muchas gracias por su compañía recuerden
que pueden encontrar este y otros
programas en nuestra web france24
puntocom
hola
[Música]